c'est un nouveau marché qui fait
beaucoup parler ces derniers mois les
nfc pour notre fille giebel token jetons
nos fongible en français c'est en
quelque sorte la signature numérique
d'un objet virtuel permettant ainsi de
garantir son authenticité et sa
traçabilité de manière incontestable
grâce à la blog shane cette technologie
de stockage et de transmission
d'information transparente sécurisé et
qui fonctionne sans organe central de
contrôle
souvent associé aux cryptes aux actifs
bitcoin étaient roms et autres
techniquement un nft et peut servir de
certificats pour tout et n'importe quoi
un tableau célèbre une paire de sneakers
officiel mais là où les nft prennent
tout leur sens c'est pour les actifs
numériques et autres oeuvres d'art
numérique dernièrement on a eu quelques
exemples jack dorsey qui vend le premier
tweet de l'histoire à 2,5 millions de
dollars le gif que vous avez forcément
vu du nyan cat 500 mille dollars tout de
même où la vieille vidéo virale charlie
m'a mordu qui a dépassé 1760 mille
dollars
mais comment faire pour faire valoir ses
droits d'exploitation sur un gif ou une
vidéo virale copier à de multiples
reprises et multi diffusé que l'on peut
trouver à peu près partout sur internet
et bien c'est pratiquement impossible
posséder nft en fait c'est un peu comme
possédé une oeuvre d'art c'est parier
sur le fait qu'elle pourrait prendre de
la valeur dans les années à venir pour
éventuellement la revendre plus cher à
terme sur un modèle plus proche encore
de l'art une oeuvre numérique réalisée
en plusieurs années à d'ailleurs été
vendu près de 70 millions de dollars
chez christie's un nouveau marché donc
les nft révolutionnaire ou pas on vous
laissera juge sans doute plus volatiles
qu'à un marché de l'art classique
fin mai il avait subi une chute de ses
ventes de 90%
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]